خائن لعائلته يفضل الاموال على الاسره
حديثه درب قاتله لارث الملكي الراحله
اوصاف الامير هاري كما تراه الصحف
البريطانيه المؤيده بعد طرح الجزء الثاني
من السلسله الوثائقيه هاريكا ذو قصه يقول
ان القصر كان يسرب قصصا لصحافه عنه وعن
زوجته
منعتها من طلب المساعده عندما راودتها
افكار انتحاريه لم يعلق السرو باكينغهام
في المقابل يظهر افراد العائله يقومون
بجولاتهم العاديه ويمارسون حياتهم بشكل
طبيعي في رساله افادها نحن لا نهتم على
العموم تاخذ العائله المالكه الصراحه
القصيره حتى العاشر من يناير اي موعد
اصدار كتاب الامير هاري الجديد الذي من
المتوقع ان يقص فيه مذكراته وتفاصيل اخرى
من نشاته وحياته داخل القصر عروب عبد الحق
والتفاصيل
لا هدوء في قصر فما كادت الضجه ان تهدا من
الحلقات الاولى من مسلسل هاري وماجد حتى
اطلقت المنصه حلقات ثلاث اخرى تضيء هذه
الحلقات على الخلافات بين الشقيقين
وبين هاري والملكه تشارلز ايضا وهي تواصل
سرد اسرار القصر الاشهر في بريطانيا
كما يتحدث عما يصفها باللعبه القذره بين
القصر والاعلام فهل يتهم القصر بمقايضه
قصه سلبيه لا يريدها بقصه سلبيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
اساليبه هل يشير ايضا الى غيره بعض افراد
العائله من
ماجدتها وكيف ان العائله الملكيه لم تسمح
لها بالحصول على المساعده خشيه ان يؤثر
ذلك على صوره المؤسسه الملكيه
اتهامات عديده وجهها ثنائيهاري وماجين
للعائله الملكيه تجعل من مهمه ترميم
العلاقه بينهما شبه مستحيله في المقابل لا
تتوقف وسائل الاعلام عن الهجوم على ثنائي
ربما بالوكاله عن العائله ورغم ان
الاحصاءات تشير الى نسب مشاهده عاليه
للمسلسل تشير احصاءات اخرى الى ان شعبيه
هاري وماجن هي الادنى بين افراد العائله
الملكيه من لندن لصباح العربيه
الشيخ همم
في امريكا
ريبوت نايف
ip
[موسيقى]
من الاردن
يسعد صباحك يعني الجزء الثاني من وثائقي
هاري وميغانا قسمت الاراء حوله هناك من
اعتبر هاري بانه خائن ومتمرد على النظام
الملكي وهناك من الاعتبار انه مجرد انه
يروي وقائع حقيقيه حصلت معه ومع ميغا ما
رايكم وتقييمكم لهذا الوثائق الذي اغضب
البريطاني
همسات
والاعلام هنا واغلب الشهادته والوسائل
الاعلاميه تصفوا بالخائن
وبدا من التركيز على الاحترام
الملكيه اللي الاميري ويلز
لديهما قصه تستحق ان يعرفها العالم ولم
تحكي عنها وسائل الاعلام يركزون على هذه
العلاقه السامه بين القصر والاعلام
ويقولون بانها
الاعلام كان
يطارده
ولكن كانت هنالك نبرا من العنصريه
لا اعتقد بان كثير قالوا بانهم
الحصول على الاموال ولكن هنالك بعض النقاط
الحامه وليس فقط مساله العنصريه تجاههم
وهذا العلاقه المسموم مع الاعلام
اعتقد بان العائله المالكي كم يقول بعض
لم اكن هنالكي تحديات همم
لهما اللي انتاجي هذا الوثائقي وهنالك
صوره مثلا لتجمع العائله المالكي لاعياد
الميلاد في
اليوم عرض الحلقه الثالثه
ولكن العلاقه بالاعلام هذه اسئله كبيره
جدا على القصر ان يرده عليها
همم المقاطعه بسبب الترجمه لانه في كثير
من النقاط نريد كنا ان نستوقف عندها ان
على كل حال ان اليوم لكي نفهم الصوره هل
هي فعلا حرب حقيقيه من قبل الزوجين على
العائله المالكه ام انه مكسب مادي عبر
نتفليكس وعاطفي لكسب الناس وكسب الجماهير
وايضا جر صفوف المترددين منهم
لكن بلا شك سيحصلون على موال لقاء همم
الوثائق لانها لا يحصل على الاموال من
العاي مالكه فما بحاجه الى كسب الاموال
ولكن
هنالك توترات حقيقيه وعدائيه بين الشقيقين
ليست
مصنعه ومصنعه
مشاكل بني هاري واخيه هو اعتقد انها تؤثر
على كل شخص في هذا الوثائق حتى الامير
وليام كما قلتم هاري ووصفه بانهصرخ في
وجهه
نقاش حول اذا كان يبقى او يخرج من العائله
هذه مشكله عاليه كبيره ولكن لان العائله
المالكه يعني مثل
المؤسسه وتوصف بالشركه
عن الناس المشكله كبيره تواجهها العائله
الملكيه ولذلك
الاعلام لعبه دورا كبيرا فيها ولكن كما
قلت ايضا اسئله خصل الاموال
لم يهاجم فقط
وقال انه كان من المؤسف ان يصرخ بوجهه
ولكن كذلك هجمه وانتقد والده وقال انه من
المؤسف ان يشير الى امور غير صحيحه كما
قال بصريح العباره هل يفهم من ذلك ان
الامير هاري لم يحظى بالدعم المطلوب من
العائله الملكه وان حتى الملك تشارلز اخذ
صفر ولي العهد
تاملي ايه
والده وهو الملك تشارلز حاليا
و
خاصه فيما يخص الدفاع عن العالم الملكي
وحتى الملكه
الاجتماعيه ولم تتوه بكلمه هي ايضا
اختارت ان تقدم المؤسسه او العائله على
الجميع
يجب ان الدفاع عن الملكيه واعتقد بان هذه
وجد صعوبه كبيره في تقابل ذلك
لا نستطيع ان نتصرف اا
كما اتصرفهاري وميغان
سوره العائله المالكه خصوصا بعد عوده بعض
الاصوات وان كانت خجوله لالغاء الملكيه في
بريطانيا بعد وفاه الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه
هذه هي ضربه كبيره لصوره العالم
قوتها همم الملكه بيعشقها الجميع في
العالم وحتى عندما حصلت الفضاء في عائلتها
خاصه مع الامير انجو فلم تؤثر على دعمها
او ال- العاطفه الكبيره تقدمها لكن
الاوقات مختلفه الان الملك همم
يعيش بلا شك الصوره من وجهه نظري همم
تاثرت خاصه في مسالتي العنصريه
وهذا الوثائق همم
التحدث
عندما نحاسي
فرحت اسئله فيها عنصريه لعامله وقعت من
اين انت من اين انت الى اخره
والاميره ويليام وتحدث وقال لا مكان
للعنصريه في هذا المجتمع
واشار الى الله كانت تتحدث بنبره عنصريه
تعتقد مساله العنصريه التي لا يستطيعون
التخلص منها ومن المثير ان الاعلام على
الاقل في بريطانيا ان يركز على هاري
وميغنكا خونه
ولكنهم لا يفكرني في مسالتي هذه المساله
العنصريه او حتى العلاقه المسمومه بين
الاعلاميه الحلقات الاولى
الاعلامه مثل جناح العلاقات العامه في
القصر لانهم يعملون عن قرب معا كل هذه
تحديات كبيره واعتقد بانها تؤثر على صورتي
الملكيه شكرا جزيلا
بشؤون العائله الملكيه لوكس